una baja más en el gabinete de sunak
dominicraft El que fuera visa Primer
Ministro del Reino Unido hasta la mañana
del viernes anunció su renuncia del
puesto a través de una carta abierta
publicada en su Twitter querido Primer
Ministro le escribo para renunciar a su
gobierno tras la recepción del reporte
resultante de la investigación llevada a
cabo por adamy Yo pedí la investigación
y prometí renunciar si es que se
encontraban evidencias de acoso laboral
me parece importante mantener mi palabra
Rav fue objeto de una investigación
independiente por abuso laboral durante
sus periodos como ministro del brexit y
ministro de exteriores la investigación
encontró que Rav había actuado de forma
intimidante y persistentemente agresiva
durante sus mandatos el Primer Ministro
regisunak reaccionó a la renuncia de su
visa a través de una carta abierta al
público Gracias por tu carta
notificándome de tu decisión de
renunciar a tu posición en el gobierno
de Su Majestad como viceprimer ministro
lord canciller y secretario de estado de
Justicia es con profunda tristeza que
acepto tu renuncia
la oposición laborista ha reaccionado al
escándalo y se le reprocha sunat no
haber despedido a antes
no sé por qué Dominic piensa que alguien
quiere oír hablar de sus lloriqueos por
tener que dimitir lo que creo que todo
el mundo quiere es un liderazgo fuerte y
eso ha estado ausente aquí porque se
nombró a rap en primer lugar por qué no
actuó el Primer Ministro más rápido
el gobierno británico anunció que rap
será reemplazado por Oliver dauden en su
puesto de viceprimer ministro